[موسيقى]
اسعد الله اوقاتكم بكل خير واهلا بكم الى
نشره الخامسه من العربيه التي نستهلها
بابرز العناوين
اغلاق صناديق الاقتراع في تركيا في جوله
الاعاده للانتخابات الرئاسي
حترمك
الجيش السوداني مستعد لتمديد الهدنه وحاكم
دارفور يدعو المواطنين لحمل السلاح
ايران تؤكد سيطرتها على الحدود مع
افغانستان وطالبان تتهمها بتاجيج
الاشتباكات
اهلا بكم الى نشاطة الخامسه من العربيه
اغلقت مراكز الاقتراع في تركيا ابوابها في
هذه اللحظات
وزير الداخليه التركي سليمان صويلح قال ان
العمليه الانتخابيه جرت بدون اي مشاكل في
عموم محافظات تركيا البالغه احدى محافظه
وتوقع صويلح اصدار النتائج في وقت ابكر من
الجوله الاولى كما شدد على ان القوات
التركيه على اهبه الاستعداد لحمايه صناديق
الاقتراع
وفي حين لم تتوضح بعد نسبه المشاركه في
الجوله الثانيه من هذه الانتخابات
الرئاسيه شهدت الجوله الاولى من
الانتخابات الرئاسيه تنافسا واقبالا على
صناديق الاقتراع حيث بلغت نسبه المشاركه
في الانتخابات الرئاسيه والبرلمانيه
88.92 في المئه داخل البلاد واثنين وخمسين
فاصل 69 بالمئه خارج البلاد هذه الصور
مباشره اعزائي المشاهدين من احد صناديق
الاقتراع في اسطنبول الان كما ذكرنا انتهت
عمليات التصويت وشرعت اللجان الانتخابيه
بالبدء بعمليات فرز الاصوات كما ذكرنا
وزير الداخليه سليمان صويلو اكد انه اكد
ان عمليات فرز الاصوات لن تاخذ وقتا كبيرا
بل اقل من ما كانت عليه في الجوله الاولى
لاعلان اسم الفائز في الانتخابات الرئاسيه
بالطبع
الانتخابات الرئاسيه في جولتها الثانيه
تتم بين
مرشح الحزب الحاكم الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان وكمال كريتش دار اوغلو مرشح
المعارضه اذا بدء عمليات فرز الاصوات كما
نشاهد في هذا القلم الاقتراعي من احد
المراكز في مدينه اسطنبول التركي
[موسيقى]
الرئيس التركي رجب طيب اردوغان كان قد اكد
ان المشاركه الواسعه في الانتخابات تشير
الى عمق الديمقراطيه في تركيا وقال عقب
الادلاء بصوته في احد مراكز الاختراع
باسطنبول انه يتوقع صدور نتائج الانتخابات
سريعا داعيا جميعا الناخبين الى الادلاء
باصواتهم بلا تراخي او تهاون واضاف ان
الشعب التركي سيختار رئيسه بدون ضغط
وسيحترم قراره
[موسيقى]
هذه المره لا توجد احزاب سياسيه على بطاقه
الاختراع والورقه ليست بطول متر واحد هناك
مرشحان فقط وبما ان شعبنا سيصوت فقط لذلك
اعتقد ان تصويت اليومي سينتهي بسرعه كبيره
لاول مره في تاريخ الديمقراطيه التركي نحن
نشهد جوله ثانيه من الانتخابات الرئاسيه
وفي الوقت نفسه لا توجد انتخابات اخرى في
تاريخ العالم جرت بمشاركه 90% من الناخبين
اما مرشح المعارضه كمال كليتش فقد دعا من
جهته الاتراك الى المشاركه بكثافه في
الانتخابات للتخلص مما وصفه بالحكم
الاستبدادي وقال عقب الادلاء بصوته في احد
مراكز الاقتراع بانقره ان المعارضه تعرضت
لحمله تشويه واسعه طيله فتره الانتخابات
واضاف قائلا ان الحريه ستعم تركيا عقب هذه
الانتخابات ذلك
ادعو جميع مواطنين الى صناديق الاقتراع
حتى تاتي الديمقراطيه والحريات الحقيقيه
الى بلادنا اخيرا من اجل التخلص من الظلم
ونظام الاستبدادي ليقترع الجميع ثم قوموا
بحمايه صناديق الاقتراع لان هذه
الانتخابات تجرى في ظل الظروف صعبه للغايه
كل انواع حملات القذف والافتراءات شنه
ضدنا انا واثق من الحس السليم لشعبنا
وبالتاكيد ستاتي الديمقراطيه والحريه الى
هذا البلد سيتمكن الناس من السير في شوارع
بلادنا بسلام
وانتقاد السياسيين كما يحلو لهم شكرا لكل
من صوت لحمايه حقوقهم في صناديق الاقتراع
لمزيد من المتابعه ينضم الي من انقر الان
مراسل العربيه زيدان زنجلو ومن اسطنبول
تنضم الي مفردات العربيه راويه القاسم
راويه ابدا معك اهلا وسهلا بكما اولا جديد
المشهد الانتخابي راويه في هذه الاثناء مع
اقفال صناديق الاقتراع وبدء يعني اقلام
الاقتراع بعمليات فرز الاصوات وابرز
مشاهداتك في هذا اليوم الطويل
اهلا بك طالب وايضا بالمشاهدين وبزيدان
يعني لا شك مثل ما ذكرت اغلقت صناديق
الاقتراع منذ دقائق قليله خمس دقائق وبدات
عمليات الفرز عاده تبدا النتائج تظهر
بالولايات الصغيره التي هي عاده معروف لمن
تصوت ولكن عندما ياتي الموضوع للمدن
الكبرى مثل اسطنبول التي نحن فيها او
العاصمه انقره او ازمير فتاخذ وقتا اكثر
لمعرفه النتائج بطبيعه الحال كانت
المشاركه في الجوله الاولى كبيره تقريبا
88% من الاتراك صوتوا هذه الجوله هناك
تكهن بانه الاعداد قد تكون منخفضه او
لثلاثه العمليه الانتخابيه بما انه
التصويت الان هو للانتخابات الرئاسيه وليس
البرلمانيه فكانت الاعداد
دخول الى المنتخبين الى مراكز الاقتراع
كان قليلا وايضا الطقس كان هناك يؤثر على
العمليه الانتخابيه احيانا يكون هناك
اعداد كبيره واحيانا
هذا اليوم كان في مثل ما ذكرنا تفاوت
باعداد المنتخبين بعده مدارس زرناها
حقيقه اغلبيه الذين التقيناهم كانوا
يقولون بانهم صوتوا للرئيس الحالي رجب طيب
اردوغان نظرا للانجازات الاقتصاديه التي
حققها اخرون قالوا نريد التغيير ونريد وجه
جديد
هذا هو ما يمكن استطلاعه ولكن اغلب
استطلاعات الراي طالب تقول بانه اردوغان
هو الفائز ينتظر ونرى يعني ساعات قليله
ويبان الخيط الابيض من الخيط الاسود اذا
صح التعبير يعني ونرى الامور دعينا انتقل
الى زيدان اهلا وسهلا بك اب رز ما لفتك في
الجوله الثانيه من هذه الانتخابات
زيدان قياسا بالجوله الاولى خصوصا نسب
الاقتراع هل كانت نسب الاقتراع اقل اكثر
ماذا يمكن ان نقول زيدا
نعم بدايه طالب تحيه لك ولراويه ولجميع
المشاهدين ما لفتنا الان في هذه الجوله هو
التغيير الرئيس التركي لمكان خطاب الشرفه
الذي كان عاده في مقر حزب العداله
والتنميه في العاصمه انقره لكن كما تشاهد
وسادع زميلي المصور يلتقط هذه الاجواء هنا
في القصر الرئاسي في العاصمه التركيه انقر
حيث نتواجد حيث جهز الفريق الفريق او
معسكر رئيس رجب طيب اردوغان هذا المكان
داخل قصر الرئاسي لخطاب الشرفه او ما يسمى
خطاب النصر وكما تشاهد كل الامور تقريبا
كل استعدادات قد اكتملت على ما يبدو ان
هناك ثقه كامله لدى معسكر الرئيس رجب طيب
اردوغان بان النصر سيكون من نصيبه في
الجوله الثانيه وبالتالي تم تجهيز هذا
المكان الذي نقف فيه داخل المجمع الرئاسي
والقصر الرئاسي في العاصمه انقره بالعوده
الى موضوع المشاركه الانتخابيه كما ذكرت
او المشاركه في الانتخابات كما ذكرت راويه
حقيقه يعني لا يمكن التكهم بنتيجه او نسبه
المشاركه لكن من خلال ما شاهدناه بشكل عام
في المراكز الانتخابيه التي زرناها في
العاصمه انقره في ساعات الصباح الاولى كان
هناك ازدحام واقبال كبير من الناخبين على
مراكز الاقتراع
عاده يكون الازدحام في وقت الذروه اي ما
بين الساعه الحاديه عشره والساعه الواحده
لكن اليوم وايضا في الجوله الاولى كان
الازدحام بدا منذ الساعات الاولى والساعه
الاولى تحديدا بما بعد بعد ظهر اليوم
تقريبا نسبه المشاركه في المراكز التي
زرناها كانت اقل لا نعلم حتى الان ما هو
تفسير هذا السبب ربما ربما كما ذكرت راويه
ثلاثه عمليه الاقتراع وان الانتخابات فقط
لانتخابات الرئاسه دون او لا يوجد
انتخابات برلمانيه وبالتالي كانت العمليه
تسير بوتيره سريعه
هذه صور مباشره اعزائي المشاهدين لبدء
عمليات الفرز كما ذكر زيدان وايضا راويه
انه عمليات اعلان النتائج لن تستغرق وقتا
طويلا ربما ساعات معدودات
يعني قبل منتصف الليل يعرف الفائز
بالرئاسه التركيه سواء الرئيس الحالي رجب
طيب اردوغان يعني في حال فاز يكون يعني
الولايه الثالثه له او كمالك
مرشح
المعارضه مع العلم كما ذكر زيدان انه
الرئيس الحالي رجب طيب اردوغان يعني يحضر
لخطاب الشرفه خطاب النصر
وفق توقعات الفريق يعني الناخب في حزب
العداله والتنميه بان الرئيس اردوغان هو
الفائز في هذه الانتخابات ولكن حتى الساعه
هذه توقعات كل طرف يعني ساعات معدودات
وتحسم الامور ويظل السؤال اذا كان يعني
الطرف الخاسر سيقبل هذه النتائج بكل طيبه
خاطر
بطبيعه الحال سنكون معكم في تغطيه متواصله
لهذا
الحدث في الامتار الاخيره من السباق
الرئاسي
التركي
لجان الانتخاب في هذا المركز تقوم بعمليات
عدد وفرز الاصوات
اعزائي المشاهدين في جوله الاعاده في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه التركيه مشهد حاسم
خاصه للرئيس رجب طيب اردوغان الذي ياخذه
الطريق اما الى ولايه الرئاسيه الثالثه او
الى خط النهايه المزيد من التفاصيل مع
الزميله روان حمزه
في الجوله الثانيه يعول المرشحان على
المدن الكبرى لكن اردوغان قدم اداء قويا
في المناطق الريفيه والمحافظات الداخليه
والوسطى في الجوله الاولى لكن نتيجه
اردوغان في المدن الكبرى التي تعد مفاتيح
الفوز قلبت الموازين وجره البلاد لجوله
ثانيه من اهمها اسطنبول قلب تركيا
الاقتصاديه والعاصمه انقره ذات الدلالات
الرمزيه للنظام اداؤوا اردوغان كان
متراجعا بالمقارنه مع منافسه في اسطنبول
حيث حصل على
46.7% اما في انقره فنال 46% من الاصوات
مفاجاه الجوله الاولى الاكبر كانت في
مناطق الزلزال فيها تايم مثلا تساوى
اردوغان وكلك دار اوغلو بنحو 48% لكل
منهما لكن اردوغان تفوق بفارغ كبير في
قهرمان مرعش بواحد وسبعين فاصله تسعه في
المئه وغازي عنتاب بواقعي
59.8
المفتاح الرئيسي لنجاح اردوغان في الجوله
الاولى كان قدرته على اقناع الناخبين بان
الانتخابات لا تتعلق بالوضع الاقتصادي
وانما بهويه البلاد وامنها وكانت الارقام
خيره ترجمه لاداء اردوغان القوي والمخيبي
لتوقعات المعارضه بزواله السياسي
رجب طيب اردوغان الداعيه الانتخابيه اسلوب
تقليدي شعبوي
وعود انتخابيه عوده مليون لاجئ طوعا اعاده
اعمار مناطق الزلزال خلال سته اشهر
توفير سته ملايين وظيفه تحسين الاقتصاد
مشروعات كبرى رفع نسبه الانتاج المحلي في
صناعات الدفاعيه الى 80% افتتاح محطات
الطاقه النوويه اكويو افتتاح المرحله
الاولى في مركز اسطنبول المالي افتتاح
اكبر نفق في اوروبا بولايه طرابزون
السياسه الخارجيه تعزيز الدور الاقليمي
الاستقلاليه السياسيه والامنيه
تبني تحالفات متعدده الاطراف الوساطه في
الحرب الروسيه الاوكرانيه
كمال كلتش دار اوغلو
الدعايه الانتخابيه تبني وسائل الدعايه
الحديثه الوصول للناخبين المحافظين خطاب
معاد للاجئين ترحيل اللاجئين خلال عامين
انهاء الاضطراب الاقتصادي انهاء حكم الرجل
الواحد
اعاده نظام الحكم البرلماني تعديل الدستور
تلبيه احتياجات منكوبي الزلزال
تحسين اوضاع الموظفين والمتقاعدين محاربه
الفساد استقطاب الاستثمارات الاجنبيه
[موسيقى]
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل معي من ولايه
مرسين عضو حزب الشعب الجمهوري في الولايه
دينيزه سام اوبلو وايضا ينضم اليه من
اسطنبول الدكتور مهند حافظ اوبلو
الاكاديمي والباحث السياسي سيدنا في مرسين
اولا هل مازلت متاكدين من ان السيد كمال
كليتشار قبله سيحقق الخارق ويفوز في هذه
الانتخابات وفي حال فاز الرئيس اردوغان
مره جديده هل سيقبل
جمهور المعارضه بهذه النتيجه بكل طيبه
خاطر ام لا
نعم ابدا في السؤال الثاني وهو الاحتمال
الاضعف ان ينتصر او يربح اردوغان هذه
الجوله في حال كان
النتائج صالح ارض فسنحترم قرار الصندوق
الانتقالي وسنلتزم بما يقررها الشعب
التركي هذه من مبادئ الديمقراطيه في في اي
دوله في العالم هذا اول بالنسبه للشق
الاول من سؤالك طبعا الجوله الثانيه كنا
نتوقع ان يكون هناك اقبال اكثر الاقبال
اقل هناك حالات من التوتر الكثيره
والتجاوزات التي حصلت في بعض صناديق
الاقتراع في في خصوصا في ولايه
الاناضول وجنوب تركيا يعني نحن نتابع
بجميع المراكز الانتخابيه
بواسطه مندوبينا هناك توترات كثيره حصلت
اليوم هناك تجاوزات اكثر من موقع حصلت
ندرك مدى التوتر الحاصل في طرف العداله
والتنميه وانا اعتقد بان هناك مفاجات بعد
قليل ستظهر في في نتائج الانتخاب مفاجات
باي معنى ايجابيه بالنسبه اليكم ام ماذا
ما الذي تقصده سيد دنيس
نحن نتوقع
الايجابيه لطرف السيد اوغلو متوقع ان يكون
هناك اقبال اكثر من قبل
اطراف المعارضه
لتثبيت التجربه السابقه في انتخابات
البلديه عندما اعادت الانتخابات كان هناك
امتصار ساحق لصالح الشعب الجمهوري ولا
نتوقع ونامل ان يكون توقعنا صحيح وان نحقق
الانتقال السلمي للسلطه ما بين الرئيس
السابق والحالي طيب ابقى معي السيد انتقل
الى الدكتور مهند دكتور مهند انت تبسمت
يعني عندما تكلم السيد دنيز عن موضوع
المفاجات
اريد ثم توقعاتكم بفوز الرئيس اردوغان مره
جديده هل لها ما يؤكدها على الارض ام لا
مجرد تمنيات وماذا لو خسر الرئيس اردوغان
الانتخابات هل ستتقبلون هذه النتيجه بكل
طيبه خاطر ايضا
بناء عليه
اذا بالنظر الى
انتخابات البلديه فهذا يعني مؤشر قوي لان
الرئيس اردوغان هو ما سيربح لماذا لان
الخدمات وهي مفتاح السر في نجاح اردوغان
تولد طيله هذه العشرين عاما هي الخدمات هو
يقول ويكرر ويفعل بانني خادم لهذا الشعب
ولست سيدا عليه واذا وقال في حملات
الانتخابيه الاولى والثانيه اذا ما انتخبت
بوني فسوف استمر في هذه الخدمات هذا
الخطاب الذي يلامس قلب وعقل المواطن
التركي هو الذي يجعل الرئيس اردوغان ينجح
راينا في اسطنبول هنا نعيش في اسطنبول
ونرى كيف الخدمات تراجعت الى اكثر من 60
الى 70 بالمئه في ولايه اكرم امام اوغلو
الوحال في انقره مشابه له اذا انطلقنا من
هذه الجمله واستنادا الى فوز مع ابشر بخير
يا اردوغان بفوز اذا هذا اذا هذا الاستناد
ولكن الامر بالفعل حساس والام
دكتور مهند جيد اسمع لاسمع رد من السيد
دنيز اوبلو في ميرسي سيدني يقول لك
الدكتور مهند انه سر نجاح الرئيس اردوغان
وانه هذا ما سيؤهله للفوز مره جديده هو
الخدمات وانه هو خادم للشعب وليس سيدا
عليه اريد رد على ذلك طيب وفي سؤال اخر
مطروح في حال فاز السيد اردوغان مجددا هل
يبقى للمعارضه التركيه اي حجه للقول ان
النظام الحاكم في تركيا هو نظام
الديكتاتوري نظام الحزب الواحد والشخص
الواحد وسوى ذلك من شعارات طالما ان
اغلبيه الشعب التركي
ذهبت الى هذا الخيار
نعم اولا ما تحدث فيه ضيفك عن موضوع
الخدمات هناك فورة وليست ثوره ثوره حصلت
من قبل حزب العداله والتنميه ما بين العام
2002 حتى
انفقت ما تملكه خزينه الدوله قامت ببيع
المرافق العامه التي تملكها الدوله الى
قطاعات الخاصه قامت ببيع الموانئ والطرقات
العامه والمطارات وصرفت هذه الاموال في
الخدمات اذا انت هذه الحكومه باعت الاصول
التي تملكها الدوله التركيه وصرفتها على
الخدمات مقابل الحصول على الصوت الانتخابي
يدرك الشارع التركي تماما ما حدث لاننا
نمر وممررنا في ازمه اقتصاديه حاده جدا
منذ خمس سنوات الى الان يعاني المواطن
التركي من هذه من غلاء الاسعار من قله
الموارد من كل شيء من كل صعوبات اقتصاديه
المعروفه لدى اي اي مواطن في العالم هذا
اولا ثانيا نحن قلنا ان سنحترم الصندوق
الانتقالي سبق وكانت هناك سباق انتخابي
حصل بين الطرف فانه تقدمت حزب العداله
والتنميه بقرار
الصندوق الانتخابي لكن ما نريد ان نقوله
نحن نحن نقع في ازمه التفرد بقرار السلطه
مع ما قام به السيد سيد بس اذا كان هذا
خيار الاغلبيه في الانتخابات هل يظل
للمعارضه مشروعيه للقول انه النظام
الديكتاتوري ونظام الحزب الواحد او لا
يعني هل يفقد المعارضه هذا الشعار
لا يفقدها نحن نحن نخاطب مواد دستوريه
يقوم بسنها لصالحه ليست لصالح الدوله
ولصالح الوطن لانه نحن نرى انه يصوم
قوانين للتفرد بالسلطه نحارب السنه هذه
ويملك صلاحيه الدستوريه لكن لكن ما يحدث
بانه يقوم باستغلال هذه الصلاحيه واتجاه
بهويه جديده للجمهوريه التركيه الجمهوريه
التركيه لا تقوم على النظام الرئاسي ولا
تقوم على نظام التمديد لاكثر من ولايه
لرؤيه الجمهوريه وقام
بعديلات الدستوريه
انه يستغل هذا ما يحدث الان
والانتخابات اليوم او النتائج التي ستظهر
بعد قليل اليوم ستحد من من هذه الظاهره
وهي التفرد في القرار داخل الدوله التركيه
وهي الاولى في تاريخ جمهوريه التركيه حتى
من زمن لم يكن هناك تفارق في قرارات
الجمهوريه طيب لاسمع رد من الدكتور مهند
دكتور مهند يقول لك السيد
اول متى تحدث عنه عن خدمات وان الرئيس
اردوغان خادم للشعب التركي لا مش صحيح ما
قام به حزب العداله والتنميه الرئيس
التركي وبيع المرافق العامه والاصول من
مطارات ومرافق
يعني هذه الخدمات في مقابل الحصول على
الصوت الانتخابي هذا واحد اريد رد ثم انه
المساله الثانيه يعني انه فوزوا في
الانتخابات يعني انه مزيد من التفرد اكثر
في نظام الحكومه في السلطه في تركيا اريد
رد على هاتين المسالتين لو سمحت
نعم هو طبعا ابتدا كلامه ببعض الخروقات
التي تحدث وهذه ربما يعني عكازه عكاز
عليها لاحقا في حال فوز الرئيس اردوغان من
انه كان خروقات وكانت هناك تلاعب بالنتائج
وما شابه والكل يدرك في تركيا بان
الانتخابات شفافه وتحت مراقبه محليه
ودوليه وبالتالي الحديث عن خروقات والحديث
عن تزوير هذا الامر يعني لا يعاش في تركيا
ولا ولم نعيشه اصلا اولا ثانيا يقول لك
سن القوانين لصالحه وكان هذه الدوله ليست
دوله مؤسسات وكانها دوله متطرفه كانها
تعيش منفرده في في محيط
بمفردها وكانه ليس هناك مراقبه لكل ما
يقوله ويفعله الرئيس اردوغان من قبل هذه
المعارضه المتعدده كل ما يقوم بها الرئيس
اردوغان هو تحت عين
المعارضه بشكل اساسي فاذا ما هناك سني
القوانين لماذا هناك برلمان لماذا هناك
ممثلين لهذه اللحظه في البرلمان اذا ما
كانت القوانين بمفرده لكان من الجوله
الاولى كان قد اعلنها بانه قد فاز
بالانتخابات والفرق مليونين ونصف المليون
وبالتالي انتهى الامر ولا داعي لجوله
الاعاده وتحت امر الواقع هذا الكلام مرفوض
الواقع يرفضون ثانيا يقول لك انها ليست
خدمات وانها بيعه الاصول وبالتالي من بيع
الاصول يذهب الى الخدمات منبع يعني وكانه
لا يرى ان هناك
مؤسسات تراقب الرئيس اردو وكان الرئيس
اردوغان هو الوزير وهو
القاضي وهو الامير وهو الغفير وهو الشخص
الاوحد يا رجل الرئيس اردوغان محبوسه
محسوبه عليه انفاسه في كل ما يفعله لذلك
يقول لك بيع الاصول طب لماذا لم تقم
المعارضه بتفنيد هذه الخدمات من خلال بيع
هذه الاصول وعرضها على البرلمان ومن ثم
القاهم بان الرئيس اردوغان يبيع هذه
الاصول وهذه الخدمات مقابل بيع الاصل يعني
هذا الكلام ايضا غير واقعي وكان المعارضه
ليست لديها افواه وليست لديها اقلام اسمع
رد من الصيدليز هو يلقي الكره في
ملعبكم في ملعب المعارضه ويقول لك انه
تركيا لا يعني مش دوله الرجل الواحد هي
دوله مؤسسات في مؤسسات رقبيه وان الرئيس
اردوغان رجل مؤسسات هناك مؤسسات تراقبه
تحكم سيروره
الحكم حتى انه قال يعني الرئيس اردوغان
محسوبه عليها انفاسه واذا انتم عندكم
ملفات تقدموا به الى القضاء
نعم اولا هو اعطل القضاء السيد اردوغان
عطل القضاء وعطلت السلطه القضائيه تماما
ومعلوم تماما ان في الفتره الرئاسيه
الاخيره للسيد اردوغان اعلنت حاله الطوارئ
مرتين
هذا اولا ثانيا تعط البرلمان وهي السلطه
التشريعيه في في الدوله كما تعرف الدوله
قام بتعطيل السلطه البرلمان التركي وحصل
الصلاحيات وتعيين الوزراء وتعيين رئيس
الوزراء في رئيس الدوله حصرا لذلك هو قام
بعمليه نقل شكل الدوله الى شكل
يستفرد فيه بالقرارات هذا الامر سيكون عبء
على الدوله في المستقبل لان اي رئيس قادم
سيعاني من هذه التناقضات في الدستور
التركي هذا اولا ثانيا البيع الاصول معروف
ومعلوم سيدي لا يعني ضيفه تتحدث وكانه لا
يعيش في تركيا لا اعرف من اين اتى في هذه
المعلومات الجسور مباعه المطارات مباعه
الطرقات وحتى معمل الاسلحه
لصالح قطر على اعتقد وتم مؤكد لصالح قطر
وبعد الكثير ما تملكه الدوله من من راس
مال ومن اصول المرافق عامه يعني حتى قناه
اسطنبول التي ادعى انه سيفتحها
وباع القناه اصلا
لوباع الاراضي التي حول القناع ولم تسمح
القناه ولم تنفذ هذه القناه فهذا كلام
يعني يعني معروف لدى القاضي اما موضوع
المراقبه الرئيس الجمهوريه وكذا قلت نحن
ليست المراقبه هي هي بطريقه كما يفهمها
ضيفك شرق اوسطيه مخابرتي لانما هناك
السلطات تراقب عمل الرئيس يجب ان تكون
موجوده السلطه القضائيه معطله السلطه
الاعلاميه ايضا قام بشراء بالكثير من من
مؤسسات الاعلاميه ومنها مؤسسه الاناضول
التي كذبت وكذبت الجوله الماضيه ودعت ان
رئيس الجمهوريه
حصل على 57% تم تراجعت ونزلت هذه المسلسل
الى 49% اذا هناك سيطره حتى على على
السلطه الاعلاميه نحن نقول نجاح حزب الشعب
الجمهوري سيعيد فصل هذه السلطات ما بين
التي دمجها في في قوه في في شكل واحد
الرئيس الحالي لنقوم بفصل السلطات ستكون
هذه السلطات تراقب نفسها وتراقب بعض
الاطراف الاخرى لنجاح عمل الدوله وعمل
الحكومه القادمه
ساكتفي بهذا القدر كنت يعني اود ان اخذ رد
من الدكتور مهند ولكن يضيق الوقت انا عم
شوفه عم يضحك على دائما وتبسم على كل من
ولايه مرسين عضو حزب الشعب الجمهوري سام
اوبلي شكرا جزيلا لك شكرا ايضا للدكتور
مهند حافظ اوبلو الاكاديمي والباحث
السياسي كان معي من اسطنبول
نشاط الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
شجار في لجنه انتخابيه بين انصار العداله
والتنميه ومراقبين من الاخضر وحزب الشعوب
الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشاط الخامسه من
العربيه نتيجه انتخابات اليوم في تركيا
تقابلها نتائج انتخابات الدوره الاولى
البرلمانيه التي تشكل عاملا مهما في
الانتخابات الرئاسيه فمقاعد الاغلبيه في
البرلمان تمنحه للرئيس صلاحيات دستوريه
اكبر
خلال نتائج الجوله الاولى تمكن الرئيس رجب
طيب اردوغان ممثلا بحزب العداله والتنميه
الحاكم والاحزاب المتحالفه معه تمكن من
الحصول على اغلبيه مقاعد البرلمان المؤلفه
من 600 مقعد بواقع اغلبيه
322 مقعدا اما مرشح المعارضه كمالك لتجار
اوبلو ممثلا باحزاب الطاوله السداسيه فلم
ينل
سوى3 وثلاثه عشر مقعدا من مقاعد البرلمان
بينما حاز اليسار الاخضر وهو الحزب
الموالي للاكراد على المركز الثالث بواحد
وستين مقعدا في البرلمان وفي ظل اصلاحات
اردوغان اصبح الرئيس الان هو من يختار
ويعين الحكومه
ابرز التحالفات الانتخابيه بالبرلمان
التركي
تحالف الجمهور
322 مقعدا تتوزع على حزب العداله والتنميه
ب 267 مقعدا
حزب الحركه القوميه 50 مقعدا
حزب الرفاه الجديد خمسه مقاعد
الاتحاد الكبير بدون مقاعد
تحالف الامه 213 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب الشعب الجمهوري ب 169 مقعدا
حزب الجيد باربعه واربعين مقعدا
تحالف العمل والحريه 65 مقعدا
تتوزع على حزب اليسار الاخضر بواحد وستين
مقعدا وحزب العمال باربعه مقاعد
ابرز مقاعد البرلمان التركي حزب العداله
والتنميه عام 2018 حازم 295 مقعدا عام
2023 تراجع الى 267 مقعده
حزب الشعب الجمهوري عام 2018 حيث 146
مقعدا عام 2023 زادت حصته الى 169 مقعده
حزب الحركه القوميه عام 2018 حازت 49
مقعدا عام 2023 هذا 50 مقعده الحزب الجيد
عام 2018 حاز 43 مقعده عام 2023 حاز 44
مقعدا حزب اليسار الاخضر عام 2018 حاز
سبعه وستين مقعدا عام 2023 تراجع الى 61
مقعدا
اما خارجيا فسياسه تركيا الدوليه
والاقليميه ترتبط الان باسم المرشح الذي
سيتم اعلانه رئيسا بعد ساعات قليله
سياستان باتجاهين مختلفين بين اردوغان
وكليتش دار اوغلو قد تغير بعضا من
المعطيات الاقليميه
اردوغانسي والاختلاف حتى على صعيد السياسه
الخارجيه ففي ظل حكم اردوغان كانت العلاقه
التركيه بالغرب متذبذبه حليفه مالت باتجاه
روسيا وكان شراء انقره لمنظومه اس 400
الروسيه سبب فرض عقوبه امريكيه عليها
اما في حال فوزك الجدار اوغلو فيعد بانه
سيصلح العلاقه مع الغرب وتكون سياسه
الخارجيه اقل شخصيه واكثر دبلوماسيه
عرقله لانضمام السويد وفنلندا لحلف الناتو
كان سببها اردوغان اماكن جدار اوغلو فيتسم
بهدوء اكبر باتجاه الاوروبيين
ساستانف طلب تركيا بالانضمام للاتحاد
الاوروبي واحرصوا على الامتثال لاحكام
محكمه حقوق الانسان
[تصفيق]
في دول الجوار بدا من خلال العمليات
العسكريه في كل من العراق وسوريا الا انك
اكد انه سيتبنى سياسه عدم التدخل دون
الافصاح عن انسحاب عسكري
لمزيد من المتابعه والتحليل ايضا اذهب الى
انقره الان ينضم اليهم هناك الدكتور باسل
الحاج جاسم هو بحث في العلاقه الدوليه
دكتور باسل يعني ساعات معدودات
وتعلن النتيجه ولكن بدي ان اعرف ما هي
توقعاتك كونك تتابع المشهد التركي منذ
بدايته مشهد الانتخابي ما هي التوقعات اي
يعني اي مرشح تعتقد انه الاقرب الى الفوز
الطيب اردوغان الرئيس الحالي هو اغرب
للفوز بسبب العديد من العوامل تجعل نسبته
التي حصل عليها في الجوله الاولى مرشحه
للارتفاع مقابل النسبه التي حصل عليها
مرشح المعارضه كماله الجدار اوغلو مرشحه
للانخفاض طبعا كما قلت العديد من العوامل
اولا اردوغان دخل هذه الجوله بوضع مريح
لديه اغلبيه برلمانيه بالتالي نسف المشروع
الاكبر الذي اجتمعت عليه المعارضه او ما
تطلق عليها الطاوله السداسيه وهي تغيير
النظام السياسي الداخلي في البلاد والعوده
للنظام البرلماني وهذا يحتاج لاغلبيه
برلمانيه لم تعد موجوده بالتالي تم طي هذه
الصفحه على الاقل لخمس سنوات ثانيا عامل
مهم التحالفات التي نسجها
قبل ان تفوتنا هذه النقطه دكتور باسل
يعني كما تقول المعارضه انه في حال فوز
اردوغان سيتجه النظام السياسي في تركيا
الى مزيد ومزيد من التمركز
وصلاحيه الرجل الواحد يعني الرئيس اردوغان
بالطبع هم يعني يتهمون الاتهام والشعار
انه نظام الديكتاتوري يعني الرجل الواحد
في اشاره الى الرئيس اردوغان والكلام لهم
هل فعلا في حال قيد للرئيس اردوغان الفوز
بولايه ثالثه الان فان النظام السياسي في
تركيا ذاهب الى مزيد من التمركز بيد شخص
واحد
يعني ونظرنا لطبيعه هذا النظام الجديد
الذي يعني هذه المره الثانيه التي تحدث
انتخابات في ظل هذا النظام هو يعطي المزيد
او الكثير من الصلاحيات عكس النظام السابق
للرئيس لكن البرلمان ايضا لا يمكن اقفال
وضعه لذلك يعني عندما تحدثت قلت انهم
فقدوا او لم يتمكنوا من الحصول على اغلبيه
برلمانيه هذا يعني ان البرلمان ايضا له
دور يمكنه المساهمه في الحياه السياسيه
سابقا صحيح ان نظام كان ربما خليط بين
برلماني او رئاسي او شبه رئاسي لكن الرئيس
لم يكن يستخدم معظم صلاحياته لاسباب عديده
اولا لم يكن ينتخب بشكل مباشر من الشعب
وكان يعني يجري التصويت عليه وفق توازنات
في البرلمان كانت دور لرئيس الوزراء الا
ان الرئيس في الوضع السابق او نظام السابق
كان ايضا يمتلك الكثير من الصلاحيات
بالتالي اليوم هذه الصلاحيات باتت واضحه
يعني هناك فصل واضح السلطات وغياب منصب
رئيس الوزراء من هذه الناحيه يمكن القول
ان التغيير ربما اسميا حصل لكن في الواقع
لم يكن هذا الاختلاف الجوهري الكبير طيب
ساكتفي بهذا القدر من انقره الدكتور باسل
الحاج جاسم البحث في العلاقه الدوليه شكرا
جزيلا لك باسل على هذه المشاركه
في ختام عشان التركيه اعزائي المشاهدين
انتشر مقطع مصور لشجار في لجنه الانتخابيه
في منطقه
بلكدوزو باسطنبول وقد افادت وسائل الاعلام
التركيه ان الشجاره كان بين انصار من حزب
الرئيس اردوغان العداله والتنميه ومراقبين
من حزبي الاخضر والشعوب الديمقراطي
[موسيقى]
الخامسه مستمره فيها ايضا
الدفاع الجوي الروسي يعلن اعتراضات تسعه
صواريخ خلال 24 ساعه فوق ومقطعتي
اهلا بكم من جديد الى نشطه الخامسه من
العربيه اعلن الجيش السوداني استعداده
للموافقه على تمديد اتفاقيه وقف اطلاق
النار قصير الامد والترتيبات الانسانيه في
السودان الموقعه في جده وقال الجيش
السوداني في بيان له انه مستمر في
الالتزام بالاتفاقيه حتى انتهائها مساء غد
الاثنين وكانت المملكه العربيه السعوديه
والولايات المتحده قد دعت الى تمديد اتفاق
وقف اطلاق النار الذي ساهم في تحقيق بعض
الهدوء والسماح بايصال المساعدات
في غضون ذلك دافع حاكم اقليم دارفور ميني
اركوميناوي في تصريحات للعربيه عن قراره
السماح للمواطنين بحمل السلاح مؤكدا انه
يهدف للدفاع عن النفس وقال من ناوي ان
دعوته لحمل السلاح للدفاع عن النفس فقط
ولتقليل الخروق الامنيه بعد الحرائق في
المدن الرئيسيه مثل الجنينه ونيالا وشدد
ميناوي على ان الوضع ينظر بالخطر خاصه ان
القوات الموجوده في دارفور قليله
وامكانياتها محدوده يذكر ان قياديا في
الحريه والتغيير اعتبر دعوه حاكم دارفور
لتسليح المواطنين خطرا سيدخل الاقليم في
حرب اهليه
الى شان اخر فقد نشرت حسابات مقربه لحركه
طالبان في افغانستان اصطفافا لعشرات
الجنود مع مركبات ومدرعات على الحدود مع
ايران في ظل توتر متصاعد بين البلدين
الجاريين وذكر واحد من هذه الحسابات ان
طالبان مستعده لغزو ايران خلال 24 ساعه
اذا صدر امر بذلك
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
وزاره الدفاع في طالبان اتهمت من جهتها
قوات حرس الحدود الايراني بانها بدات في
اطلاق النار على الحدود الافغانيه قائله
ان الاشتباكات في محافظه كنج بولايه
نيمروزن دلعت بسبب اطلاق النار من الجانب
الايراني
واوضحت ان الاشتباكات تسببت بمقتل شخصين
واصابه اخرين من كلا الطرفين
قائد القوات البريه في الجيش
الايرانيث حيدري قال من جهته ان الحدود
المشتركه لبلاد مع افغانستان هي تحت
السيطره الكامله مضيفا ان وجودهم على
الحدود لا يعني ان هناك اي خطر يداهمهم
لكنها اجراءات استخباراتيه وامنيه معتاده
موضحا ان الاوضاع المستتبه تعتمد على مدى
التزام الدوله التي يتشاركون الحدود معها
بالقوانين الدوليه ومشيرا الى انه في حال
لم تتبع طالبان القواعد فستواجه موقفا
مختلفا
اعلن المتحدث باسم وزاره الدفاع الروسيه
اعلن ان الدفاع الجوي الروسي اعترض تسعه
صواريخ خلال 24 ساعه واوضح كوناشينغوف ان
القوات الروسيه اعترضت ثلاثه صواريخ كروز
من طراز ستورم شادو وستتواريخ من راجمات
هايمرس الامريكيه كما تم اسقاط اربع
مسيرات اوكرانيه على محاور القتال في
جمهوريه دونتسك الشعبيه ومقاطعتي
النشاط الخامسه المفصله من العربيه انتهت
اطيب التحيات والسلام عليكم ورحمه الله
وبركاته
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات